gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you stand up comedy plus
we've played the Leo IG with the crowd
shows are selling out and you can get
your tickets at rugarbage.com see you
there
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
group to be classy yeah or to just a big
old piece of trash I'm your hostage
Foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here at titties in the
new edition she is down at o'hallah
hands okay for eight Cent wing night all
right 20 nose beers my co-host is coming
at you from right now
thank you
yeah Michael is coming at you right next
to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is
an international businessman but always
the king of the boardwalk baby give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what's up
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking and obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com
garbage gang you go over there you get a
bajillion hours worth of bonus content
patent pending check it out yes sir and
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer X Jordan Air the old Magic Man
Marks the ones the twos the threes and
the fours he crosses the t's and he dots
the eyes give it up for T-Bone
McStuffins Toby McMullen everybody what
up boys oh we got two absolute all-time
dudes in here you can take these guys
out and have the best time of your life
they'll tell you they love you and
they'll scream right in your face
just the way we like it baby just like
home gang the long hair ain't lying
cause we got two our absolute best here
in the studio today uh uh they are the
hosts of the stuff Island podcast two of
our best Pals in the whole wide world
give it up for Tommy Pope and Chris okay
let's go let's go little garbage island
boys are back yeah
we want to do this every week yeah when
did when Toby get intro privilege yeah
he's always had intro privileges I
didn't know I didn't know it's been
getting stretched out I've noticed a
little bit too but I like it we rip off
I like it too I love not criticizing I
just want to know I found like a shot it
wasn't a shot he got a lot of nerve with
that first day of school haircut too
much
like you got the picture and Tommy took
him
he went to the bar he's like take off
four inches of happiness
I swear to God a year ago Toby would
have to raise a finger well we didn't
have five mics at the time we didn't
have the capabilities but then
patreon.com came along and now we can
afford more money congrats thank you
congrats uh this is you guys
I don't know
I don't like that you're really being
refined with these wine glasses I know
I'm over here drinking bud how you oh
you are double fisting I completely
changed my mood I came in here Furious
hey it came in I got to watch the
Charleston I get a little white wine all
of a sudden I'm back yeah baby back in
Wildwood yeah
Connie how you doing he goes I'm on
water
why what's wrong dude dude you never
know I just this morning
first of all they lived together they
came separately so I don't know what's
going I had no idea where the other one
was going shopping he's going lunch
dates and stuff I don't know yeah I went
to Keynes at a couple old Fashions a
nice steak sandwich you did yeah did you
go by yourself I got a stuffed moose
head
it's nice
I could show it one
that's why it's
because you buy yourself I do I love
eating by myself I used to feel bad for
old men that did that [__] now I just
yeah enjoy it you're an old man who
doesn't yeah I [__] love it dude did
you throw in the pinky ring because you
were going to Keens no I bought this
because we shot something called tires
shout out to tires shout out McKeever
girl of course
and a bunch of other and I mean um
me and Andrew Schultz are called the WAP
Brothers there you go so I was like I
need a pinky ring for this role ah and
also maybe I wanted one for myself yeah
he hasn't taken them off since we shot
yeah so I got that that I get to this
nice little Arab kid Sam shout out Sam
from Alex's jewelry I always said I
wanted he's already looking believe that
yeah
why don't tell him what Julia go to fans
will show up there
that's what we going to every time we
love him because people will hawk me I
didn't do me or him yeah you did he
always goes cause your [__] fans are
gonna show us nobody cares getting
sexually assaulted which I did last
weekend
I walked into a bar time these girls
back there boots you did now what bar
was that shut up
shut up
anyway I asked this boy I was like look
I'm also in this in the in the shop it
for a circle circular pendant that's not
religious and he said we have a custom
piece just came out would you like to
see it I said I'll take it and then I go
my Chain's not heavy enough I'll take a
chain and he goes I'll throw in a
bracelet for half off man he saw you
coming oh man so now I'm gonna I
complete the package right now and I
feel good about it
the Eagles
losing and winning throughout Sunday oh
you smash the [__] out of it that's real
gold though yeah it's 14 carats
clean are you garbage what is he what's
the pendant huh what non-religious
pendant it's a lion okay my God yeah
this is lion versus religious right it's
got to have some religious connotation
somewhere back in the days it's corny as
[__]
a lion I had a dragon as a kid and
that's I got ridiculed for that I didn't
put in the trash it was just finished a
dragon versus I like it looks nice it
looks nice Tommy so oh Connor what
happened what's the problem well I ate
lunch by myself I don't
I was asked to leave the restaurant
dude I spent 400 on scallops
there's nowhere to eat here I didn't
know I went in I just went just went
into a place where's scallops for lunch
dude I don't know some Greek place I got
scallops I'm all over the [__] place
you're the only guy who would be like
there's nowhere to eat in New York City
yeah exactly around here I'll take the
scallops around here what was it gonna
do go to Crazy golf or whatever that
[__] place is somehow there's a line
out the door for that four o'clock which
makes them mad for no reason
that made me mad who the [__] going to
Crazy Golf don't you people work I don't
think there's even golf in there I think
this is the name of a restaurant yeah I
don't know I don't know anything about
the place but wait so how did you decide
the place you went to lunch that
bothered you so bad I panicked
I went to a place I thought I saw I
found a place on Google Maps that I
thought would be a regular bar it turns
out it was a rooftop bar to a hotel oh
man that was close
here I am getting sucked off by a
Bolivia where are you traveling in from
I live here
to a hotel for lunch generation the same
thing he goes what's the occasion why
are you guys here anyway let's see I
live in Queens dude dude I [__] hate
that the steakhouse I'm [__] here for
dinner mine you're [__] business the
only option you gotta go to a steakhouse
run there's a lot of high-end
steakhouses I don't know I feel like if
you're not in any one of these places
for a business lunch people are like
what the [__] happened yeah it's like I
don't know I don't know where to eat
yeah
the only place was at Delhi that I'm not
gonna stand on the corner and eat a
sandwich I wanted to sit down
okay how are the scallops scallops were
great
so what's the [__] problem and this
is how angry he is with himself sounds
like you had a nice nice lunch yeah did
you get an appetizer no you just got it
that's bread they had this puffy Greek
bread I don't know what I don't even
know how to it's like a puffed Pita okay
they're called rolls
you guys gotta get out more balloon
are these Bagels
dude I want to take a picture of it to
show you it's hot it's [__] yeah what
happened I cook it in here curls your
hair you don't put the hair on oh [__] I
went to go get my hair cut I get that
care my haircut from the same guy every
time and I was the last time he cut it
was two months ago and I was just like
just make it two months sure wait hold
on haircut after lunch no it was before
okay so haircut then lunch yeah then I
thought that haircut came with a
lollipop
little airplane
so it's crying they just spin them
around a couple of times
what's a haircut cost you what's that
cost you a little 20 bucks 20 bucks
cut that in hand what barber school was
that at
dude Empire Beauty School is for felons
dude there's there's one on Steinway
they are the most hood [__] in the
world dude they're weird sideways and
they're [__] fighting out there that
usually gives me a great cut but I was
sitting there and I was making great
conversation with them
Chris known conversation yeah yeah
exactly you can imagine what a rare
event this is so I'm like I'm riding
what are you throwing at him are you
asking questions or you're just
answering questions well dude I I was
just I got I was lucky to draw so what
do you ask me no yes
summer and I said I have no [__] idea
anyway me neither dude [__] Blue by
oh now we're off now you're off you're
off on time what is time it's a
construct now o'conny's in but then he
then like as he was cutting my hair
shorter and shorter I got quieter and
quieter
not enough to speak up but just but I
didn't want to break this great
conversation we were having yeah I've
been getting bad haircuts where I come
up with the excuse that I'm gonna tell
my friends of hat like I'm like this is
already bad I'm gonna say he was a new
guy the English wasn't great yeah
something something yeah I moved my head
he did he had to go lower than I wanted
yeah
the Latino was taken I went to a Serb on
the other chair you get [__] up oh the
Eastern Europeans they it's that's a
Loveless thing they grab your head
they're [__] oh yeah send you to the
front lines
angry their wife looks exactly like them
well he's a gay guy and every time
they're like Eskimos dude their wives
look exactly like them I don't know why
he had to drag the eskimos my dad I
think that was that I think that was
Defensive talking they go from 18 to 68
in a [__] year
seven years every one year who are we
talking about Russians yeah it's they're
Fair it's like it's like it's like you
know when you go to Fox News Tommy let's
go
yeah their faces are it's like when you
go to like New England in the in the
summer and you see like like you're in
like Nantucket or something that weather
beaten wood siding yeah yeah
you know what I'm talking about yeah
gotta get the roof read done
it's crazy exfoliate a little bit how
have you guys been I haven't seen you
since what the for sure I know we did
have a uh if you're on the patreon you
know we had a magical yeah magical week
down the shore
um where we never really talk publicly
too much about it uh oh sorry about that
um
you two are crazy people we've I've come
to the conclusion I'm not we're nuts you
two throw it into a fifth sixth seventh
gear oh right that you're like around
midnight it gets hairy with you two what
are you talking about the Cucumber
you know what I mean I went to bed it
was three and you guys are blasting Phil
Collins I thought there was 30 people on
the deck I look out it's just YouTube If
you're not gonna feel at the air tonight
we won't be here I mean I love Phil just
as much as the next man you talk about
psycho who walks away from that yeah 100
you're down the shore you got the Bay
right there you got Phil Collins blast
you go to bed when this track's over
Dude fighting the bay Karen every night
at midnight was the fun I mean that was
some of the most dangerous I've done a
lot of dumb [__] as a young kid but I
mean hurricane Force storms yeah you
guys are jumping in the bay like it's
[__] walking around the marsh so fun
well if you swim all the way if you can
fight it all the way across you just you
go in that it's like [__] sauce it's mud
yeah you're just yeah you're falling in
mud if you risk your life you get to sit
in mud for a half hour
still digesting this burger
and [__] sauce is beautiful I should have
had the scallops nice and light I was
referring I was referring uh when you
said crazy I thought you meant when uh
O'Connor and Barris us at the ebit room
in Cape May New Jersey accosting the
waiters it's [__] hammered dude yeah
I thought we were having a good time
black down angry
never seen you guys show so sheepish
quietly you looked like it was your
first time in church let's let's show
you for everybody to be like Jesus Chris
calm down what's the problem yeah
I saw you guys yeah exactly it was an
old lady she remember that old lady
table I was like yeah oh you know
somebody's crossed the line when you're
at dinner and they're and they're and
they're not talking to the other table
but they're directing the conversation
in their table yeah what do you mean
well I'm not doing it yeah you believe
these [__] I'm gonna sit with these
guys because you guys wouldn't shut up
about what a problem I was being we
couldn't you were being a problem I had
to appeal to
Jersey Shore there we we know we look it
up first of all we didn't have the right
clothes to get into it we were borrowing
each other's collared shirts so we could
get in yeah I was wearing a fly fishing
shirt
like three oysters in my ass crying
fighting the tides the only thing that
passes in college
and we Chris got wildly upset I would
say is the word at us listening to the
waitress tell the specials yeah it
bothered you for some reason that we all
got quiet that's what really triggered
you yeah really the fact that we were
quiet and you didn't want to be quiet
while we were like oh what are you gonna
order the specials who orders the
specials we're just being polite
you know you didn't need to hear this
did you order one of the specials I
didn't exactly yeah we didn't need to
hear the specials you're not wrong no
one got it right you just gotta let the
girl run out of battery and then we
order what we want no no
but from spending she doesn't want to
list the specials either no she's been
working all night this is her [__]
showcase yeah
they got us they got to sell the
specials seven o'clock it's like you
doing the Charleston the first time by
like 10 when we walk in she's she has it
rehearsed yeah
is that what you're telling me she also
made fun of you a little bit when you
mispronounced the wine and he did not
like that
how dare you yeah something about Sans
Sarah
yeah he's not sincere all right well do
you have it
you're on the edge of creation right now
surprised you didn't get flagged at
dinner
but then I did it was one of those I I
I've been that guy I've been that guy
everybody here has been that guy
obviously not cheating on you just it
was you were just that guy that night
and you wake up in the morning and I'm
making coffee you come down you're like
man you ever have the worst part of your
personality show out in front of all
your friends
just like my hangover anxiety when I'm
an [__] is bad my hanging over
anxiety when I think I'm fun is so much
worse yeah I wake up the next day and
I'm like I was
you popping and chatting with people I'm
like what I said to that waitress
I'm just I lay in bed and [__] nailed
it these people are friends with you
what are you out of your mind it could
be worse you could have walked down like
last night was great right oh yeah which
is totally black dial it up again yeah
hey I think that server was into me yeah
that's when I knew I was in trouble you
guys were trying to convince me at the
end of the dinner then she's like she's
into you oh yeah you're like what about
her friend over here they got a napkin
wrapped around your head
creme brulee in your hair
will you time to get off uh you guys do
have a thing where it's like instinctual
one will be crazy the other one will be
perfect and then at some point in the
evening or the next day because Tommy
was the next night at the at the bar at
the at the place of Wildwood yeah dude
that's why there's a yin and yang you
two [__] monkeys know too sure no of
course but they also think the other
one's crazy they think they're saying
and they think the other ones apologize
sometimes every day both times on the
shore each one has come out to me like
but you're not isn't me I'm like yeah
totally yeah but here's the thing when
we're saying that we're right I'll give
you that and that moment you are more
sane this is crazy you know what I mean
one's acting insane then you calm down
you go that guys what do you guys want
you know you want two nice waitresses to
hang out with you for a week down the
shore no you want a little excitement
you want to get on a knife fight with
your friends you want you want two
buddies risking deaths that's what you
one I remember you did come down to me
the next morning you're like looking
back you did get through to me in the
car I you told me I got 30 in the car
ride home when I went Chris we're six
professional comedians what you thought
we were just gonna sit there in silence
all the time like that hit me like a ton
of bricks
he's screaming at me in a car and a guy
is not happy and then he turns over to
the Uber driver goes you get breakfast
around here
the guy was like get the [__] out of my
car those two were screaming at each
other
but yeah the fight on the way home was
nuts it wasn't nice we were going ham on
that car in that car I don't I'm I don't
think Chris remembers much of it all
right home what no
good let's move on
my memory
no you do we were just all you two were
yelling I was trying to we had a blowout
fight he had a blowout fight I love how
the one doesn't even remember this uh
you're just screaming like you do I'm
sure we'd already covered it some other
fight yeah yeah exactly
it was a recap it was a recap of [__]
you [__] you you always do this you
always do this what are you doing yeah
I'm sitting in the back texting them
like I got in the wrong Uber okay let's
talk about that men mobile do you like
mint mobile are you just doing the ads
no [__] you asked me anything like
this my family's been using mint mobile
for about four years five years and you
know why because it's 15 a month gang
while everybody else is jacking up up
their prices mint mobile is here to cut
you a break to the first company to sell
premium wireless service online only
that way they pass the savings on the
year yeah uh they have phone plans
starting just 15 beans a month like the
big man said that's a ton of money that
gets to stay in your pocket instead of
paying hundreds of dollars somewhere
else
uh all mint Mobile plans come with
unlimited talk and text and high-speed
data or data delivered on the nation's
largest 5G Network I love that 5G it
couldn't be easier to make the switch
you keep your same phone your same
number and all your existing contacts to
get your new Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get that plan shipped
right to your door for free okay go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com garbage gang Hey fat ass
let's talk about Factor oh shout out to
the facts talk about thinking some
pounds off you there tubby huh skinny
mini like me sure I like my factory
meals number one meal kit uh-huh sent
right to your door right to the door
fresh never Frozen you throw them in the
microwave or do them on a skillet like
you like it's ready in two minutes I'm a
big fan baby like that turkey jelly uh
shout out to the shredded chicken taco
bowl
uh helps you fuel up with Chef prepared
dietitian approved meals straight to
your door you can do keto you can do
Locale which I'm on down 12 pounds no
big deal shout out to factor I would use
a factor
since before they were even a sponsor I
found them about three years ago on an
online ad I clicked on I said let me try
this what's the worst that can happen if
it's bad it's bad I waste one week it
was six a night oh baby I'm doing
everything it's fantastic you choose
from over 34 weekly meal options that
are fresh never Frozen You Can level up
with their Gourmet plus options with
premium ingredients like leeks truffle
butter and asparagus uh if lunch times
are hectic Factor has you covered too
you keep your energy up with lunch to go
meals no microwave required and they're
ready whenever you are so here's the
turkey gang head to factormeals.com
garbage50 and use code garbage 50 to get
50 off wait what yes that's card that's
code garbage five zero at Factor
meals.com garbage five zero to get 50
off do it gang yeah let me guess so I
was gonna say how do you guys feel about
that do you guys I mean obviously when
you're drunk it's one thing but when
you're in the back of an Uber are you
saying whatever or are you or are you
cautious or or
are you thinking of the driver at all
they were making personal attacks at
each other and then Chris asked them
where to get pancakes like immediately
after like like a stone cold killer I've
never seen anything like that it's like
an XL right so it was like a huge uh
right it was like um no weed a Suburban
no we were in a Corolla yeah you were
like a Celica my knees were in his back
he was in the front seat I didn't take
into consideration it wasn't that bad it
was pretty bad it was it was not great
I can't use lift anymore
yeah
yeah but it's like one of those blowouts
we have blowouts here and there
obviously but so do we I'm a big
proponent and it comes it's because
[__] up families I'm a big proponent
of a blowout you gotta get that
especially you're running a business in
a company with with someone who's
essentially your partner and your wife
and you gotta get some [__] out if
you're not getting out on a consistent
basis if you don't have a normal
emotional conversation about things on a
consistent basis it just builds and it
[__] explodes when it explodes we're
very good about hugging saying sorry
about that I love you yeah we move on
yeah yeah
it wasn't that bad otherwise I'd
remember it
yeah but you were just it was 19 glasses
you were in Another Universe
we also had the longest day ever that
was like 12 hours of boost yeah you were
drinking yeah I think
I started well I had that espresso
Martini yeah
I should have laid off that Cafe yeah
espresso is why I acted up
you said eight ball and Coke I'd be like
yeah that was probably it to learn about
that it's the last time I have Splenda
again I'll tell you that my rib eye was
dusted in the espresso it was the last
drink you had at dinner and you're after
ruining you're like yeah it was that one
that's the one that does it that's the
recap because that was sober enough I
think I ordered the Uber
Maybe
I don't remember I remember standing on
the street having a nice time this
beautiful Street it was a beautiful
Street Cape May New Jersey yeah Jersey's
all right Cape May sucks
it is not my uh it's a little too
reserved for a guy like me of course a
guy like you look at the ramp look
around the table I know yes I enjoy that
I like a nice nice quiet town I don't I
don't feel like I belong yeah I want to
go I want to go where we were at Seaport
pier and then my whole family walked in
I was like this is a place my family
hangs out like really this place is
trash and then every single member of my
family I think Foley was the most
dressed up he had like a a button down
with pineapples
who the [__] are you guys the mayor he
walked out of the ocean
dude yeah that's how I felt going I get
[__] Greek food around here I was
just I I don't make you sit at a table
or the bar back I sat at the bar yeah
that's a good move that's a good movie
on a rooftop though no no no this was
ground level I I nixed the rooftop I
couldn't do it okay yeah did you look
online is that how you found the place
uh I just want a camera following you
with 24. there should be just to see the
decisions yeah there'd be a lot of
editing
I was Furious yeah the whole time I I
just I just found a place and I walked
in but you were mad because I just don't
understand why why you were mad because
it makes me uncomfortable being there
and I don't like places that make you
feel unnecessarily uncomfortable I swear
to God this is true and he'll back it up
two hours ago I had to stop him in the
walking through the kitchen going hey
are you mad at me
and he's like what no well and I was
like well you you haven't looked at me
you haven't asked a question or like we
haven't talked we're just passing ships
and it's like now I feel like he's mad
so I gotta ask him I get worked up he's
like no I'm just mad
mostly from within it's myself yeah yeah
and I'm like talk to me what's wrong
so this is like a normal process at
least you got that dude one time with
him we were sitting here I go you want
to go out and smoke a cig he goes no I
go I walked out and smoked a cig I put
my steak out he went out I was like can
I [__] your wife or something What's
Happening Here Jesus Christ I'm like
nothing on that I even I didn't know how
to approach I told Toby he's like I'm
like
he's upset with me right dude
I who know you you know you're a whole
different level yeah that's crazy I was
thinking about how and a little
embarrassed about how like how mad I was
about the the Diaz episode getting uh uh
flagged yes and how crazy I acted about
it we were in a pool and you were
actively turning your back to me while I
was swimming around no I haven't been
haven't been nabbed like this in a while
yeah
it got it got because something he said
it got 18 agents or whatever
so it like you know it could have done a
million views or whatever and it did it
just you know it was cooking and then
just got [__] shut down at Toby for
not editing out the thing that was which
we found out at this point he knows it
was not anything he did it was not our
fault it was it was the powers that be
was nothing we did yeah the algorithms
we had confirmed that with everything
this was just pure crazy I was thinking
about it yesterday dude the three of us
were in a pool in Tampa a small pool a
small pot in Tampa yeah and he is he has
his back to us in the pool the whole
time and we just remember like hey Foley
wonder whatever and he would just turn
like slowly the thing was I was I was he
would just I'm like you're icing me in
person in a board what's going through
your head at that moment it was so crazy
I say nasty things and you don't want to
say them so you're just going to look
the other way or do you or no we had
already said a lot dude we got a fight
in the airport yeah yeah I'm screaming
at him I'm like I'm like [__] playing
off I'm like let's blow up I'm like I'm
like I'm not getting on the [__]
plane for you but ignore me for the rest
of the [__] yeah like I'm not doing
this this is crazy but I was thinking
about getting on the plane I'm not
kidding I'm yelling and then he goes you
better lower your voice or something it
was like a it was something in implying
that if I didn't do something you could
hurt there's going to be consequences
he's like a raccoon in a trash can dude
don't don't give him an ultimatum no
cause I'll see the worst side of that
even if I don't want to I will walk
through it I don't care so he goes he
goes you better lower your voice I go
what are you [__] threatening me and
I didn't realize we were standing next
to the TSA yeah they're looking at the
two tsa's looking at me I'm screaming
threatened they're like like let's just
lower our voice and go get breakfast but
what I was thinking about is how crazy
oh there's bomb in my bag right now
I'll take it all this whole thing up
hey we're talking about the podcast
I do think I'll put a pin in that
there's something so it's not healthy
but it's healthy in our lives of like
you gotta get that out yeah
probably not that when you're putting
your shoes
a difficulty tying your shoes
let me borrow your shoes
back on yeah why is he wearing sandals
in the winter one second please
no I was thinking about because the way
I was thinking about my behavior from
that yesterday and like Tommy said
because Tommy Cassie and I took a took
an Uber to the that's Tom airport Tommy
c yeah I'm Tommy
he's Tommy too nice time okay he's Tom
Cassidy yeah
that's the whole body is looking at his
nails let's do this again
all-time active
that's a home run baby
garbage island baby we're back
um because no Tom and I went to the went
to the airport together and I was
totally normal with him this is when
we're getting to that airport and then
and then when I got there it just turned
on anyway I was thinking about it it
survived the flight that's what's so
impressive oh it survived you got on the
plane flew landed so we were at the
airport the light went to the hotel
we're talking sound check meet and greet
the whole night you know it started wait
wait when was the pool was the pool
before the show before the show yeah
yeah so it started at the airport yeah
no get through the air starts at the
airport you do your show yeah or you do
the pool do the pool they all get
dressed we all get in a car we all go to
the show side splitter shout out great
Club shout out to him uh go to the club
we're at the club we're doing sound
check we're in the green room and the
Green Room there's tiny it's like you're
this tight yeah and he's still icing it
was like a nail bomb ready to go off I'm
okay he's still icing T-Bone in a
cubicle yeah he's ice and T-Bone in a
Cuba but I wasn't mad at Tebow we talked
about this but I wasn't mad at you I was
just mad sure and then I offered that it
didn't break until I offered him an
olive branch of a sugar-free Red Bull
oh you got one which I spit in
but he was wise too I know your tricks
fat man
dude I'm outside smoking take this out
of the lab that sucks for two because he
probably didn't even want it but he's
got to take it
I wanted it yeah I'll take the red one I
wanted it so bad but I didn't want to
take it from here yeah yeah I know when
my sweet baby wants a [__] sugar-free
Red Bull I know when he's thirsty
it is a uh
being created as a myself it's a
constant Minefield and we were just
talking to someone about this of like
you think someone's mad because you're
conditioned of sometimes how you talk to
each other like Chris isn't talking
you're like [__] he's upset at me yeah
and you're like you up and then you kind
of in your head you're like did I do
this is this what he's mad at and then
you're like oh no not at all and when
you spend that much time with someone
there's an infinite list of things it
could be seven it could be I didn't
respond to a text quick enough I made a
joke yeah or he made a joke that got
through I left my toothbrush on the sink
yeah it's always weird when you write
Jesus rough households it's weird uh
like with me and you when I'll do
something where I think you're mad and
then I'm waiting for it and then so I
already start to fight in my head I have
that with you and then and then it
doesn't happen and then it doesn't
happen and I go man and then it'll
happen it's like I've already built the
bombs I gotta use them I gotta sell
these off to some countries got to get
these yeah give me Egypt on the phone
you get three red shells in first
uh yeah it's it's real tough with us
because we've you know we've been
working together so long and the
dialogue
there are sometimes I have I mean we
both have we're both I would say it's a
60 40 with communication based on uh
when he's in a when he's got us when
he's got a thorn on his side yeah it
really resonates yeah via text wear it
on my sleeve Tommy get it out he'll hit
you with like a no I don't get it out
but you know but they know it's there he
starts laying them the groundwork and
I'm going this is gonna suck tonight
yeah you know what I mean yeah yeah it's
noon and I'm in for a [__] day yeah
with a blow up at 8pm let's just talk
about it I'm like normal people I like
to stretch it out this is exactly why I
stopped him in the kitchen because I was
like we got to do ayg today we have to
go you're mad at me let's do it now
let's figure out what the [__] is
because we have to go because yeah but
there's something so healthy I don't
like doing it now yeah he doesn't like
doing them so
um so we have to see how big this
balloon can do that's why yeah my
five-year relationship should have been
two and a half so I'll figure it out
later
because then then you can feel the other
person's stress building up yeah and you
hope that they snap and then you can go
outside
hey it's nuts and then you showed three
shells right now
you're [__] useless
oh where's the remote where's the remote
cart's just spinning around you don't
know what's going on your mom died
because she's dumb knock all these coins
at him
anyways
it sure was fun yeah
that was one of the best weeks of my
life sure was fight free witches I want
to go back on as far as I'm concerned
it really was it really in o'connorland
it was fun yeah we were there seven days
Chris was only there six
mentally he was gone for 24 hours man
that's so true you had the time of your
life yeah damn you had the best dinner
you ever had it was white wine and clean
laundry
you're doing all right
oh [__]
um I've never seen I'm bad with with
airbnbs and laundry but I have never
seen someone show up with towels and
sheets before he's dirty dude he brought
a bag of dirty laws I didn't have time
to separate him I stopped everything in
there and took it it's great it showed
up like Johnny apples
whose pillowcase is this you should have
tied it on a stick Like A Bug's Bunny
cartoon ah
um but I am very surprised between you
two there was no fight between us two
there was no fight and between the four
of us there was no fight because we're
all very comfortable with with each
other and and which like a point in that
if I was like crazy upset
with somebody at that point I could be
like you you know it's you're so
familiar at by day two yeah even we also
have known each other for over a decade
so you as you get to this age and you
know how much
pressure it takes to to
I don't know do dumb [__] like this you
go okay when you have your own personal
time I know what you like to do I know
what you like to do you know what we
like to do if it's not aligning just
everybody yeah they gotta separate the
[__] time frames and like just figure
out what you want to do to calm the [__]
down but hold on there's a comment to
that even though we all we have known
each other all along time even friends
have known each other 15 20 years
sometimes you put them in a house
together oh yeah they just don't gel
yeah we [__] were like the guys and
Goodfellas in prison yeah everybody was
dude yeah everybody everybody did their
role Tommy was doing the cooking we're
doing the dishes we're cleaning up every
day we're [__] hanging out I was
responsible for keeping the energy up
keeping us on their toes
we're eating breakfast he's throwing
flashbacks everybody
what's up we would stand on the deck
yeah I had a lot of quality time with
O'Connor and be broken it in and be like
I don't remember even what we were
talking about but every night ended with
my head hurting from last year yeah
right back here yeah oh dude this is
crazy it was uh
it was when I was giving him fashion
advice and I was sitting there with my
shirt off
mommy said I was naked
they were [__] on me about my
clothes hey Tom because you're gonna
listen to him he's naked and it was just
like he was wearing Haynes with six
holes in it no he had a nice outfit on
and Foley was complimenting it and you
actually went I thought you were like
feeling good about yourself and you go
Tommy goes you're gonna listen to him
he's
me
so in the middle of you having a nice
moment feeling good in your clothes
oh what the [__] that [__] cut Tommy out
of this episode no I was supportive I
was trying to pump you up for taking a
risk also Chris is taking a ribs put the
collar on his wrist no you're nuts I can
drive I can dress all right I've never
seen you with a collar me yeah yes you
have
collar when do you have a collar on I
mean not I don't know who's the last
person
I went to my stepdad's funeral in
January
it was a mock Turtle name
it's still a color
he would have wanted it that way we
buried him with his Lions to you Angelo
um no but I remember we were going out
to a nice dinner I did have some sort of
collar on and I I had a khaki pant
cuffed which I I do a cuff and I had
white tight cuff like high school
no he looked fantastic it bothered I
walked down he goes what the [__] is
this
he goes where he goes he's got white
shoes on he was disgusted by myself yeah
well when you see someone growing in
front of you it's a nightmare I thought
we were [__] together I went from
Bobby Hill to [__]
oh no but it was it was one of those it
was it was uh I realized it was a very
wholesome I mean it was debauchery for
seven days straight no I know what
you're saying it's a perfect balance of
both it was a very wholesome we we
talked we all talked so much about life
we haven't seen each other since we
haven't seen each other since yeah no
just texting and it was one of those
weird things of like your leave we're
all leaving you're like oh [__] this
kind of sucks it was like summer camp
for what you don't get I always get
older I was genuinely sad because okanie
had to leave a night before because he
was filming I was genuinely sad when you
left yeah yeah okay let's talk about
butcher box butcher box butcher Butcher
box butcher box one of our absolute
favorites baby let's pull the curtain
back I got bacon coming out my ears but
it's fantastic and let's be honest you
go to the grocery store these days
everything's super expensive he got
loaded up with antibiotics you don't
know how long it's been sitting there
butcher box we're talking free range
we're talking wild caught we're talking
pasture raised we're talking top quality
grass-fed red grass finished beef yeah
it's fantastic like we've been saying
for years they ship us I'm talking cargo
crates worth of meat today I'm giving it
to the neighbor I got nowhere to put it
dude lost hamburgers how to get a deep
freeze for my bedroom about to open a
restaurant and we're talking 100
grass-fed beef free range organic
chicken yes pork that's raised crate
free and wild caught Seafood you can
seriously taste the difference Gang
butcher box even gives you the recipe
inspiration tips tricks for making the
most of your delivery and here it is
Butcher boxes giving us a special deal
babies drop in sign up today at
butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg to get 20 bucks off
your first order baby that's
butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg to clean this deal cold
hard cash back in your pocket do it
again go back to the show let's go I
feel like most people at our age groups
yeah yeah
yeah just expand the Zone yeah
most humans
Paulie's here I'm right here yeah we're
all within 10 years of each other [__]
people from our age groups your only
option of having that summer camp Vibe
is like a like a bachelor party yeah and
most which is too much pressure on
people that you don't [__] care for
and you don't have that deep connection
with throughout the the week or weekend
sure so leaving that's like God I can't
wait to [__] yeah you're like this
was yeah the nights are fun but I want
to get away from those guys yeah this
was a very
um yeah if you have that opportunity to
have special friends and take it take a
five to seven I would have stayed
another week baby me too yeah it was one
of those things I'm like it it it the
drinking and heaters and food took two
years off of my life I'm like but I
gained it sounds horny but I'm like I
gained two years of like Joy of joy and
happiness and laughing wisdom we were
just talking about I don't know about
that shut up oh shut up cut that fully
ripped the ladder out of the dock dude
did you guys talk about all the [__] uh
we talked about someone we talked about
a good amount on the patreon uh when we
were down there obviously we we did two
episodes with the boys uh oh yeah I was
on it uh yeah you were there Tom
yeah
I think you were wearing that shirt to
be honest with her I got you got Irish
Amnesia you only remember the bad stuff
yeah it's true that's pretty good yeah
that's all right did you just come up
with that no I saw in a movie
so you're a drunk
yeah my barber told me that today
who was blind by the way
guy works off all of you
oh my God
Chris you are IMDb The amount of movies
you watch is outrageous dude he came in
pickled where were you Shane no I wasn't
that bad but I was tired uh was that the
Jets game do you want a wire yeah I'll
take a beer actually what do you want uh
you want your you want your wine
you got a whole bottle of Kim Crawford
back there white cloth
uh yeah him and him and Shane went and
uh little sass went to the Jets Bills
game
I couldn't go but uh
yeah well it wasn't it was a shame
and he came in he came in I bought my
ticket start to count start to movie it
like [__] what time what time is it
like three 2 30. it started at 1 30 and
I left at 2 30. okay yeah so I watched I
can't I gotta finish it
because I always yell I know you said
that that's weird it's also a fiction
what do you mean it's fiction because
you went I had to stay up and finish
this thing you got caught jerking off
and then by who
who caught you first of all can we
publicly talk about it hold on hold on
hold on [__] did that come from O'Connor
this guy
you want to do this what you got caught
jerking I was gonna say that you stole
my punchline that's the whole thing
no I didn't then he [__] at me about
having to finish the movie and I quit on
him and then I come in last night and
he's watching the end of the movie
because he didn't finish it I had to
re-watch the last time what movie
Public Enemies with jobs oh very good
yeah yeah yeah
that's a great ending too I have to
finish it you know who's great in that
is the guy that goes and sees the girl
at the end when it's all over yes
oh he was an avatar that guy yeah yeah
but he's one of the Texas lawmakers they
get off that train [__] gentleman so
good anyway yeah I did get I paused it
at one point tell her I said Blackbird
or something like that right bye-bye
birdie or something yeah Tommy said hi
hi birdie
Library
which is also my theory about down the
shore when he paused Goodfellas when
[__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah when Raley has like
beating the [__] out of his wife it was
just paused like mid hit and Tommy was
like upstairs for some reason he's like
no no it's just time for bed no because
I knew that was there's another hour and
45 minutes there
so what to finish the movie who caught
you jerking off
yeah oh your girl she just was like what
are you doing I was like Wow nothing
like you got no answer to that she knew
that's not that bad I thought one of the
boys
were there any pumps we just talked
about it yesterday on the podcast does
that start things up or is that
oh no she was like trying to get me yeah
like you'd rather jerk off on the couch
to a crime movie yeah then lay in bed
later just [__] me yeah
that's not what it was though I didn't
want to bother you she's trying to get
some anxiety you'd say no yeah yeah
yeah this is unbelievably hot in here
now
by your significant other no uh not
caught I never once can we talk about
substantial evidence yeah can we talk
about this yeah about you guys yeah yeah
you guys
wail on yourselves well on yourselves
like you're in prison got high tastes
crazy yeah yeah you two would just
disappear separately I'm not saying not
saying it's a stuff Island go Venture
you would disappear you guys were just
crazy you ready for one more
I don't know what you guys do on patreon
we'd be sitting there you guys would
just disappear and then you come back
and like oh it's just jerking off is
that what you were doing
you guys jerk off you've told me the
number I won't say publicly but to me
it's crazy I mean it's like sick
teenagers well we don't have any other
tools to deal with our feelings
so that's kind of where we go to
okay so anytime anytime the pot's
boiling over
yeah which as you can imagine is yeah
just bring a little salt in the water
you know what I mean you ever went in
your backyard and screamed [__] as loud
as you can yeah that doesn't work as
well nowhere near beaten off but it
still releases like a lot of anxiety and
sure
some people do yoga some people meditate
to people scream into a pillow yeah well
that's my mind I wail on myself
when my friends are home
he's just going at it that was the scary
part because I was I jerked off while we
were there too yeah so did I for seven
days yeah at night before I went to bed
yeah yeah every night not every night
no they were they were no I didn't the
thing that's weird the thing that's
weird is they were during the day we'd
all be out together
we'd eat lunch they'd go back to their
quarters that is weird Tommy dude Tommy
doing nooners I don't know that yeah you
guys are doing Tuesdays like you're in
high school yeah well sometimes it's
hard to face the day and you know you're
just coming down the stairs at 2PM
whistling
no no no unless we spend a day on the
beach looking honey
that's also not how we jerk off we we
jerk off and then
oh everybody does then you just you just
walk out of course yeah full of Shame
yeah still worse you're just shaking off
cobwebs that's all it is yeah again you
got to clear the pipes I gotta get to
get a level head uh uh yeah that's just
it just seems
exuberant or it was all it was it was a
lot uh to the point where
Midway through
they were because you know you guys are
also in shape you got the blood pumping
we're out of shape we're old speak for
yourself
talk to my wife you call me jerking off
did she
no that's not a hidden thing necessarily
in your household really well it's my
wife uh no I don't hide it I mean I'm
not like making scrambled eggs and doing
it but it's you know so you might have
to do it I do it you hide it what do you
would you shame your girlfriend or wife
if you caught him beating off no that'd
be [__] that'd be hot yeah it's
different when you're a fat disgusting
47 year old man no it's not you look
great you're in there pulling your bum
in there pulling my peter everybody's
got to do it so you know everybody I
agree yeah but he has to use car jacks
to get his gun out of the way and a
series of mirrors to see what's
happening
if I'd be kind of pissed
of course you would might be a little
bit what the [__] yeah oh cause it's a
missed opportunity for you yeah like
I've been jerking off for four times
yeah yeah but you're probably you
probably are coming out of my eyes
she's got me asking if you forgot you
turned her down I know I never turned it
down
someone asked you never once turned on
sex uh to your girl I don't think I ever
have only one time I was and it was my
uncle you know it depends on how active
I've done it I've done it when they they
they used it to try to get out of a
fight
ah damn that's real crazy that is crazy
it's real crazy
there was one time I was cooking I was
cooking with my girl and we got in a
fight and she went into the room and put
like sexy lingerie on and walked out and
I went
no you think I'm gonna forget about what
you said at dinner every time I'm
jerking off I regret it
man
man and I let my ego get in the way yeah
man you are twisted it's crazy
but I like the fact that you still jerk
off to it that's that's my speed I like
that yeah that's that's a sad state of
when you're jerking off to missed
opportunities
I feel like I feel like a lot of a lot
is sad a lot of my that is that is
missed opportunities
which they removed yeah
or you'd be like yo I saw you had red
hair and I saw you on [__] 82 bucks
if you ever see this I want to eat I was
in a drive-through at McDonald's my
credit card got shot down you walked by
yeah I think we could have been
something
just praying there a creep on Craigslist
too yeah does that ever worked do you
think definitely I I can't remember who
it was maybe for a sec I would read them
from time it was somebody we know it's a
friend of ours did that and he ended up
and and the the girl did
meet up with them she she was she was on
it too I think for a minute that was
like a message yeah it was like like
before Tinder and all that stuff or it
was because it was so Centric I do
understand the concept but like I have
like two or three misconnections in
terms of like energy like feeling
somebody something from somebody sure
they're looking at you and they want you
to say something you just don't and you
think about it for months type [__] but
like a mature adult would never be like
I gotta go on [__] my space or some
[__] but that was definitely my dad that
was very of the time it was it was cool
it was like this like Uncharted
Territory Reddit type what can the
internet do yes it was still at that
point yeah
it was still at that point it was still
like yeah what can the internet do yeah
yeah sounds like a mess is it what they
say it is besides make me hard as a rock
you sound like a mad scientist like
you're pitching the internet to the
government it is dude you realize the
capability
actually connecting on a misconnection
on Reddit would be as close as you get
to making I think T-Bones got some stuff
it's a lot of people striking out
dude
far eating Scout
and scalp
it's just a gay bartender like there you
were I was gonna approach you but you
were stabbing your forearm with your
fork yeah you were there typing on your
laptop
I was there
what did you have your laptop now she
did who did
this is my missed connection oh yeah
it's a fake woman he's talking about no
it's a real woman she was there
oh you connected with a woman at the
stake I didn't connect at all scallop
house no I just shoveled a shovel Scout
I went to a gallon yeah let's follow his
garage
yeah I went to a fancier restaurant and
ate like I was at a buffet it was just
shoveled scallops in my mouth chugged
gin and tonic which was very flavorful
and then I just bounced also how long
did our feces smell like Bay water to
you
you guys were drinking a lot more Bay
water than uh yeah it was probably that
it's probably our swimming dude it
smelled like low tide I never heard of
something like that for four to five
days yeah you get those we talked about
it when we were down there your [__]
smelled like Bay Water you said yeah but
that was some of the Olympics
the baywater gets into your system I
think so yeah what have you heavily we
were swimming you got to get someone in
your [__] hole Yeah in your butthole
now your face oh your mouth your nose
again that's not what makes the Bass
smell like the bay is the salt water
it's the decomposing uh mollusk which is
awesome yeah look at those enzymes
so it's tap water up top and then [__]
on the bottom you got some bad meat no
no when you're really exerting yourself
your butthole opens like you got sleep
apnea or something you know what I mean
it just like opens a little bit oh you
think you're gonna pop in the bun yeah
yeah I think I think it just opens a
little bit yeah and some water gets in
there yeah some of those no yes you get
that you get you swallow enough of that
water your poop will smell I mean that's
a big I'm a big proponent of that you
see like Olympic Swim or something
is that about 400 of them
oh my god do we even want to get into
questions sure yeah let's do a couple of
cues got the boys here yeah they always
do a couple uh this way I I try to pull
some very Philly based trash this is
from Logan never have one red is it
garbage to put cigs out with your bare
feet oh no which I've done as a kid
crazy callous the cows is so heavy I
think if you get it quit it's like a
it's like a lantern fly if you get it
quick enough it dies like you don't feel
it if you step on it real quick I would
do it as a kid with my dad's never see
this car right there that's cars from
putting a cigarette out thinking it was
funny in college yeah I got one too I
got one on my uh
what do you think we found it yeah I got
one on my wrist do you oh yeah Kev
where's yours you [__] right there you
[__]
real group of losers we got mine just
don't brag about a [__] mine was from
when I was a kid mine was when I was a
kid and they said that I walked into it
but there's no way somebody oh yeah
remember you talking yeah I don't know
who I don't know who it would have been
Diane somebody put put a cigarette yeah
I probably dessert you probably munching
her buffalo chicken dip she was fired up
again I guess not even here yet it's not
garbage if you're by yourself if you're
doing it in front of chicks because you
think you're gonna get [__] that is
good well putting a stick out on
yourself no with your foot yeah oh with
your foot I mean yeah it sounds like the
guy in college that would put it on his
tongue to try to look cool wait why
would you put it out or flip it you
remember the guy that would flip it in
college they could they stay in a
lipstick yeah and have the the Cherry in
their mouth yeah yeah it was from Police
Academy
I'm sucking my finger way too long
really yeah cause I have like a very
concave
uh top of the roof of my mouth okay it's
crazy it goes all the way up that is the
most Ginny [__] yeah that's crazy I
could do a whole a whole flip of a
toothpick I suck my tongue for too long
too how long did you do it till I sucked
my finger
really yeah I suck my thumb until sixth
grade just did like this yeah like this
and I would play with the the appendages
it was a really sad kid he was trying to
tell people
yeah I got phonics tomorrow mom is this
what you want he killed me
I would suck my thumb and I would pick
my nose and get like a hard booger right
here and I would just rub it oh that was
my move yeah real well adjusted no I
like it yeah good for you I did that
until about sixth grade yeah and then
they really put the kibosh on it this
guy no I would I would take a booger but
this is gross but I put cheese on it
a little parm cheese just a little
lacitella you know what I mean he's
messing up a little bit you know I would
I would get it had to be like the right
kind of Booger too and I would I would
like stick it to the front of my nose
and I would rub oh my God as I suck my
thumb I don't know what that was all
about well I did the thing with the yeah
I liked cult like this was very cold and
then the back of your Achilles was cold
so I would hold that while sucking my
finger I think I was I did all the way
to like second or third grade my little
cousin which was crazy that's like 34
dudes my little cousin when she was a
kid when she'd lay in one of them These
Guys these two are nuts
damn I know I'm in bad shape but I'm
teaming up with him
about how crazy our co-hosts
like Mel Gibson and [__] Danny Glover
on the cover me and Tommy are sucking
our thumbs and rubbing your boogies
trying to find a booger yeah
isn't the right consistency I don't like
that one give me another oh God damn uh
all right let's see here this one's from
Susie is it we've never I don't know
this has ever been broached is it
garbage to take communion in the mouth
and not in your hand
communion
dude I always were you did you do
community were you I did I did I went
the hand for the non-catholics out there
it's when you receive the body of Christ
the little wafer at the end of uh
Catholic mass I don't know if the other
Christians do it again I lost my mind
that's pretty good yeah
Church snack he called Jesus yeah
as a kid I thought we had to and it was
the 80s and I think when we got
communion the priest would make us do it
but there was always something weird
about it what in the mouth yeah
going up there like that [__] hours
of his father Tom and his [__] mitts
weren't getting anywhere near my oh yeah
but now put it in the hand it's a wrap
Foley's guy was going eye contact eye
contact
you're wiping my hair
my mother became a Eucharistic Minister
like 10 years ago I would have never
gone to her no offense no never I never
I never not not the female thing I get
it I never went in the line because
sometimes they had the people that help
like the eucharest man oh I didn't mind
though that would do that would do it on
the side now what the [__] what are we
doing here no I'm not going to a
Broadway show and not seeing Bette
Midler I want [__] priest to do it
right oh yeah yeah it's not holy water
from the pope yeah no I'm fine with that
person the body of Christ yeah I'm not
getting that from some guy who's also
doing the parking outside
no dude no I'm totally okay with it the
priest index smells like the altar boy
I'd rather have the keys of a [__]
Miata in my mouth
my mother would refuse so like some old
bat would open her mouth with her wine
stained [__] veneers and my mom would
go no no hands
yeah get out of here
Sick [__] you do it you filthy [__]
how do you think this is grow up
check your left pocket she's just a
magician I don't know you signed up for
the gig yeah no she's wrong yeah I do
get you I respect
yeah that's creepy we're in enough
trouble as it is yeah you're trying to
get me jammed up
I do not read the papers have you not
seen Spotlight yeah
such a funny way to quit that job just
flick the thing at her face correctly
dump the body of Christ
father I can't do this anymore
I wouldn't have then that would never
fly that was creepo status to me even
the dudes if you requested it
you might as well be a swinger I I tried
to do I tried it once just to see if
they would do it and they did it yeah
they got it I would never for like I'm
gonna say one or two years out of my
eight year I went to uh Catholic school
for 12 years but two of the eight years
in grade school what
it's [__] funny man
funny how two of the eight years I would
I'd pretend I go like this you step to
the side you bless yourself then you
throw it in and I would just go no you
put it in then bless yourself and you
would fake it wait why why didn't you do
it because it gets stuck to the roof of
your mouth it does I mean it tastes like
[__] yeah it's rice paper it's kind of
like the body of Christ so what did you
do grow up what I love it so what'd you
do with it what I loved it stuck to them
yeah
I hear it insane asylum pretending you
took the pills I'm just humming yeah and
then just drop it in the view leave it
in the Pew Tommy if they would call yeah
you would have been [__] you think
yeah like
what do you think I was leaving it for
yeah it was like a trail of breadcrumbs
right to your locker dude it's like
Indiana Jones it's like don't take it
past the seal
you have chosen poorly
the whole church starts crumbling
someone left with the Eucharist
all right let's do one more then we
gotta wrapper up here gang uh
uh this one's from Brandon ten dollar
homie just subscribed is it garbage have
furniture in your garage like a recliner
and a sofa do you remember down the
shore yes to me that is the height of I
understand that it's trashy I'm not
trying to say it's not it is the height
of luxury
for a teenager or their 20s we're out
there you can it's a house you can crank
heaters at you can have beers I would
say it depends on the Aesthetics once
that garage door opens it depends on
what it looks like out there 100 yes
it's like being on like a porch That's
is it nice or not sure Florida room if
it's good yeah it's good if it's bad
it's bad garbage it's [__] terrible
it is it's like planting the seed of
like a punk band
it's when it started a recliner in the
garage yeah yeah it's like a Blink-182
song
recliner red where you said and I love
you it's actually not bad
printed get my guitar do you remember
the Nostalgia watching the Phillies
during that storm with the yeah with the
door open but that was a very classy
version of it down the shore because
that was a very nice house yes it still
wasn't that cool I mean it was I was the
classiest version I ever had of it I
mean it was unfinished garage like you
know whatever working out on the bay and
also it was nice your furniture was a
big screen TV we used to do it as like
we would find my buddy would my buddy
Justin would find a couch on the side of
the road and throw it in the back of my
buddy's pickup truck take it and he's
like oh we can put this in my garage and
we just put like used couches in the
garage and we'd sit there because we
were allowed to smoke cigs in the garage
setting up somebody's garage oh man that
was a game changer TVs in the 90s where
I had like a 10 inch screen but like a
50 inch projections yeah it's like 180
pounds they were the [__] it went so far
back I remember those before big before
flat screen Sony made those real big
ones the big silver ones that were like
kind of flat they were flat screens but
everybody had them it was so deep and
they were so [__] heavy
crazy I could barely fit them through
with doors where it had like ridges on
yeah outside screens yes yeah brutal
I don't remember one time hanging on my
buddy's garage got a handle of pop-off
vodka like to play just pop off like a
nine dollar annual vacuum we were
drinking screwdrivers all night
listening to Billy we just discovered
Billy Joel oh my God we did we were 16.
I'm [__] 19 screwdrivers deep dude
cranking a Marlboro mile oh my God and I
fell right into a picnic table and
smashed it like I was Chris Farley I was
like sing us a song
that's why you walked out on Phil
Collins I can't do it seen this story
before I had memories
he got halfway up the screen door nope
I'm going to bed
never again
gang boys we [__] love you gang check
out stuff Island you guys got anything
else coming up you want to let the folks
know
uh we're in Indiana next week there you
go no we we're starting to we're gonna
uh check out the patreon check out the
patreon
the numbers Tom we're gonna do
all right I'm taking that as a personal
offense that is a personal attack
against me I'll handle this the boys
haven't absolutely not you're following
me so nice dude you can buy tickets to
all their live shows at rugarbage.com
I'm sure you listen to stuff found but
if you don't you gotta check it out it's
absolutely amazing podcast
thank you so much of course of course
check out their patreon right like And
subscribe just link this stuff when I
say LinkedIn limp describe
we've been on there he's not indeed I've
got no traffic we've we've done a bunch
of their patreon episodes they do a
cooking show that we've we've done they
have a crab oil coming out from down the
shores coming out on their patreons
gonna be on ours as well but check it
the [__] out there's a [__] ton of
content Tommy and master in the [__]
kitchen it's going nice and the bedroom
we just started a 10 tier by himself
I was in my seat if I did that you'd be
apoplectic
where you guys record the podcast yes
that's wild that's a public place open
and out pants down or under a blanket or
something I actually went underneath
because I was still wearing my I changed
into some running shorts ah those are
nice I went down I went up this way five
inches you must be home
anyway thanks for bringing that up Chris
thanks so much for your friendship yeah
and Future
remember that time yeah we we [__]
that out
that's it that's all I got let's eat
Kitty what do you got for him uh guys
we're all over the road tickets are at
re garbage.com shows are selling out
[__] get them now we love seeing
everybody out at the shows a lot of
these boys thank you again we love you
T-Bone we love you and gang we love you
and we'll see you next week